you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact for most people
prison is a place you want to escape
from but for some South Koreans in
desperate need of a break a day or two
in an imitation Jail is the escape since
2013 the prison inside me facility in
Northeast Hong Kong has hosted more than
2,000 inmates
many of them are overstressed office
workers and students seeking relief from
South Korea's hyper demanding work
expectations for $90 a day clients can
check themselves into a prison where
they get a blue uniform a yoga mat a tea
set a pen and a notebook they sleep on
the floor there's a small toilet inside
the room but no mere prison rules are
strict no talking with other inmates no
mobile phones or clocks the menu
includes rice porridge for breakfast and
steamed sweet potato and a banana shake
for dinner you might wonder why would
someone pay to be incarcerated while
South Koreans typically work more hours
per week than any other first world
country this extra stress leads to a
very high rate of suicide among business
professionals and students Park Harare a
28 year old office worker said this
prison gives me a sense of freedom I was
too busy Park said as she sat in her 54
square foot cell the prison co-founder
no jing hite said some customers are a
little apprehensive about spending a day
or tool in a prison cell until they try
it after stay in the prison many inmates
say this is not a prison the real prison
is the hectic life we return
to friends you know the Bible says there
are many free people out walking the
streets who are actually prisoners of
sin stay with us we're going to learn
more on this edition of Bible answers
live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answer to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in the CDs program
call 888-814-3923 am four eight hundred
four six three seven two ninety seven my
name is doug batchelor my name is john
ross good evening friends and pass the
Duggars we always do let's stop the
program with prayer dear father in
heaven we thank you once again that we
have this opportunity to open your word
and study together we want to invite
your presence to be with us be with
those who are listening and once again
father guide us in a clear understanding
of your word before we asked us in Jesus
name Amen amen
pastor dougie open the program by
talking about people paying to go to
prison usually when you think of prison
that's not something that people want to
go to but I guess life is so busy there
in South Korea and of course it can be
that way for a lot of people even in
North American around the world that
take a few days off even if it might be
in prison is something that people
welcome you know a few years ago I was
doing a week of prayer out of prison and
I stayed at a hotel where there it was
out in the middle of the desert this
prison is a desert but there's a hotel
nearby
and I was trying to finish a book and I
was
kind of in a prison myself during the
day in the evening I'd go and do a
program with the prisoners and I kind of
thought you know this is quiet it was it
was peaceful kind of getting away from
just all the stress and so we were
saying for we went on the air we've both
kind of thought it wouldn't be bad for a
few days to just have no stress no
problems no responsibilities and kind of
know what there's nothing I can do I'm
in prison I can't I can't do anything so
why worry but it just tells you about
how people are so stressed that they're
just there looking for a relief now the
Bible has a lot to say about prison and
it draws some spiritual analogies about
prison you can read for instance in
Isaiah 42 7 talking about the Ministry
of Jesus it says he came to open blind
eyes to bring out prisoners from the
prison those who sit in darkness from
the prison house and again you read in
Isaiah 61 verse 1 the Spirit of the Lord
God is upon me because the Lord has
anointed me to preach good tidings to
the poor he sent me to heal the
brokenhearted to proclaim Liberty to the
captives and the opening of the prison
to those that are bound so much of Jesus
ministry was about saving people from
prison and matter of fact the whole
Exodus story is God saving a nation from
the prison of slavery and bringing them
to the freedom of the promised land
that's an allegory for what he wants to
do for you friends as to save you from
your sins now he not only wants to save
you from the penalty of sin which is
death but believe it or not God can save
you from your sins and give you victory
over your sins people then always wonder
well victory over every sin how many
sins how do I stop sinning can you stop
sinning and there's all these questions
about how far are we supposed to go or
do we work our ways to heaven by
fighting off sin we've got a book with
an intriguing title don't let the title
scare you
but I think you'll be encouraged the
book is entitled is it possible to live
without sinning and good question we'll
be happy to send this book to anyone who
calls and asks again the book is called
is it possible to live without sinning
and if you'd like to receive the book
for free
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven and just asked for the book
called is it possible to deliver that
sending that number again he's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and if you have a Bible question
our phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven and
that'll bring you right here to a studio
and I think we're ready for our first
caller this evening we've got Andrew
listening in Tennessee Andrew welcome to
the program dig me pastor Ross Webster
good evening so I have a question
regarding the let me see how they put it
is basically there's no there's no verse
in the Bible it says that the Virgin
Mary or the mother of Christ ever
consummated the relationship with Joseph
therefore certain denominations believe
that to remained a virgin prior during
and after Jesus Christ there what does
the Bible say about that no the by I
don't think the Bible teaches that it
tells us that Joseph and pastor Ross are
looking up this specific verse the Bible
says Joseph knew her not until he took
her his wife but it says he knew her not
until the child was born and so
everything in that leads us to believe
that after Jesus was born they had a
normal marriage relationship why
wouldn't they you know the idea that
that Mary lived out first of all that
would have probably been pretty lonely
for her and Joseph they were legally
married
oh why would she what's the point of
that there's no sin in married people
being intimate and the Bible says the
married marriage bed is undefiled and so
I you know it really comes from paganism
that a church is sort of built a
doctrine that Mary was not only a virgin
before but she stayed a virgin
after nothing in the Bible teaches us
that the verse you referring to pastor
die he's Matthew chapter 1 verse 25 for
it says speaking of Joseph and he knew
or not till she had brought forth her
firstborn son and he called his name
Jesus you know we've got a website it's
called Mary truth dot-com and it it
actually tells
about both Mary Magdalene and Mary of
Bethany and Mary Magdalene rather and it
talks about Mary the mother of Jesus
there's a lot of confusion about these
characters especially since that Da
Vinci Code book and so if you just go to
Mary truth you'll find some great
information there that explains that
Mary why she was a a godly woman nowhere
in the Bible that is to say that she
remained a virgin and you know the
Immaculate Conception is not talking
about Jesus being born of a virgin it
says Mary was born through Immaculate
Conception so it almost deifies her
nothing in the Bible teaches that so
hope that helps a little bit Andrew does
that make sense
yes it does I could never understand why
they said that because the Bible says
Jesus had brothers or Signum writers and
sisters so yeah now it is probably true
that the brothers and sisters of Jesus
came from a prior marriage of Joseph but
that doesn't mean Mary was a virgin and
there's other reasons for believing that
when Jesus is dying on the cross he
commits the care of his mother to John
Jesus would not if he was the oldest he
would not have left home and become an
attender at preacher so you know it's
it's very likely that these were the
stepchildren of Mary that Joseph also
Joseph dies way before Mary does he's
probably dead when Jesus begins his
ministry because he's never seen in the
picture again so he's probably older had
another family and these are like a half
brothers and sisters of Jesus so hey I
thank you for your call Andrew and we
appreciate that you very much take a
look at that website Mary truth com next
one that we have is Katie listening in
Los Angeles Katie welcome to the program
hi good evening evening I want to know
if it is my responsibility to pay for my
husband style we have a separate bank
account and we just share expenses you
know is it my responsibility to pay
tithe all right let me see if I let me
just restate what I think you're asking
so your husband is not a believer he's
not practicing but he doesn't pay tithe
she doesn't play that team believes in
diet but he doesn't does he have a
separate income from you yes we are both
social security but on taxation he has
income yeah you don't need to take
responsibility for his decision and his
income you can only really be
responsible for yours and so you would
hope that would be his decision to you
know give offerings and tithe if he
doesn't you you know you shouldn't be
shouldn't be taking that out of his
account or you're not responsible to pay
twice as much for him out of your
account it's a change of heart that he
needs it's not that God needs more money
so does that make sense Pass for us
mm-hmm yeah yeah we do have a study
guide that talks about this I don't know
if you've seen this before Katie but I
think you'll find it helpful some good
information about tithe but also
offering the biblical principles for
that is called In God We Trust and we'll
be happy to send us anyone wanting to
know more about what does the Bible say
about money
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven and you can ask for the study
guide called in god we trust'
pastor that you just preached a sermon
this weekend on the subject of money and
yet I think that'll be available in a
week or so on Facebook or YouTube and if
anyone wants to find out more was a
great biblical sermon series actually
it's on it's probably on my Facebook
page now I know it is yeah okay
it's called how to find freedom from
debt mm-hmm how to find freedom from
debt focusing take a look at that as
well thanks for your call Katie our next
caller that we have is looks like we've
got Andrew listening from Dayton Ohio
Andrew welcome to the program hello good
evening thanks for calling yeah my
question um basically I'm looking for
somewhere in the Bible where I can find
an example of you know the battles that
men are faced in order to become
righteous and uh you know receiving
salvation
you know from God and it's just just the
best examples that I could study
well of course no man obtains
righteousness through a physical battle
he had some great battles in the Bible
from you know David and Goliath to
Samson but they didn't obtain
righteousness through the battle there
are examples in the Bible where people
battled temptation successfully and
Joseph I think of the story where Joseph
was tempted by his master's wife and he
was very courageous willing to go to
prison rather than commit adultery
that's quite a battle that he fought as
a young man and so you've got you've got
the spiritual battles is that really
what you're looking for you're looking
for just men who battled for
righteousness through you got the
stories of you know Peter and his
repentance from sin and and he goes from
being a coward to being very brave he
denies Christ and then he tells people
he's willing to die for Christ so he
goes for quite a transformation oh yeah
yes definitely I was speaking about you
know the spiritual the spiritual battle
you know the inward you know the
temptation everything that you have
mentioned so yeah that's you know where
I'm at so I just wanted to see David
went through some great battles he you
know he fell but he found repentance and
you can read the story of his repentance
in Psalm 51 psalm 32 and how he ended up
overcoming and becoming you know a
righteous leader once again you know we
do have a book that you might find
interesting
it's called the armor of God and it
burns about how we can live a victorious
life perfect and the Bible gives us some
very practical ideas or resources that
can be used and we'll be happy to send
this to you Andrea if you just call and
ask for it
the number to call is our resource phone
line that's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and you can
ask for the book called the armor of God
and we'll be happy to send it to you or
anybody who calls and asks the next
color that we have is Gavino listening
from San Antonio Galena welcome to the
program yes
good evening pastors evening there's a
verse I think it's a revelation it says
that
Jesus Christ has given power from heaven
above and earth below
my question is didn't he have that power
already and why is he be giving this
power over again well it'll help to look
at the particular verse I know it tells
us in Matthew 28 where Christ says all
authority is given me and you're
mentioning revelation pastor Ross I
think is doing a search right now in
Revelation but I think if you go to
Matthew chapter 28 I can we can address
that one to start with Christ of course
had all power before you you can read
where John says in the Gospel of John
all things that were made were made by
him so and that's Matthew 28:18
all Authority has been given to me in
heaven and on earth is that the one
you're talking about yes yes I was wrong
on the chapter yeah so that's Matthew
28:18
Christ is reminding the disciples that
Jesus had all authority it wasn't just
given to him after he rose from the dead
he had it before he came into our world
Christ laid aside his power and
authority in divinity when he became a
man obviously he's a little baby he's
not exercising a lot of you know cosmic
authority so he laid a sign he humbled
himself became like a human laid aside
his divine authority in power after the
resurrection he's reminding the
disciples I'm I'm you know been real ora
fide again I'm with the father and all
authority has been given to me so I will
I'm your friend and I'm gonna give you
power to do the work I'm telling you to
do okay alright well that makes sense
and did he have to relearn everything as
he was growing up of who he was
yeah you know and this is really amazing
to think about but when Jesus a pastor
in Ross and I were just talking before
the program about this very bright baby
girl who had a phenomenal IQ but I think
Jesus when he was born he had to learn
to walk and talk like other children he
you know his neighbors that knew him
growing up did not think that he was a
magician or a sorcerer or some special
person they said isn't this the
carpenter's son
so for his neighbors and family friends
even his own brothers they knew he was a
godly man but they were shocked to learn
he was the son of God they came to
believe it so he must have seemed like
another child and learning like other
kids weren't okay all right thank you
yeah I probably was all the people
wonder at what point did Jesus
understand his divine mission and many
think when he was 12 years old and he
went to the temple with his father God
revealed to him during that Passover
that he was the Lamb of God and so it
probably started to dawn on him about
his 12th birthday and the the reason for
that is because of the answer he gave to
Mary and Joseph when they found him in
the temple and he said did you not know
that I must be about my father's
business
I think they began to realize Jesus also
began to understand his mission there
next what we have is a Kenny listening
from Indianapolis Kenny welcome to the
program Kenny you're on the air you
might have your mute on Kenny
Indianapolis Indiana you still with us
all right we might come back to Kenny
here we have Denise in Rhode Island
Denise welcome to the program hi can you
hear me loud and clear okay great
my question thank you for taking my call
by the way appreciate the work that both
of you do I really do um I have a
question that I've thought about for a
long time I have never been able to ask
anybody about it
we know that Jesus says that in heaven
we human beings will not be married or
given in marriage right but so in
Revelation we are told that Jesus will
be coming for the church and the church
will be here right so what are your
thoughts about that I know there's no
marriage but there was a marriage what
do you think about that yeah that's a
good observation you know when Jesus
says there they're not given in marriage
in heaven but they're like the angels
someone was asking so do Adam and Eve
get their divorce papers when they get
to heaven well you know what the Bible
says what God joined together let not
man put asunder
when Christ says they neither marry he's
actually using a verb in other words
there are no new marriages but if if
there
a couple here on earth and they've
enjoyed you know 50 years together an
uninterrupted marriage they can hang out
together in heaven they will be no
procreation there and there'll be no new
marriage is there but I don't think God
is handing divorce papers out to people
who go to heaven that love each other
and want to be together you know what
I'm saying so but you're right that
ultimately we are married to Christ the
church is consider like the New
Jerusalem that comes down out of heaven
like a bride and the Bible says we are
invited to the marriage supper of the
Lamb and the Bible says husband's love
your wives as Christ loves the church so
the church is like the Bride of Christ
Jesus was not married because he's
married to the church she used a lot of
wedding language in his sermons thank
you so much I appreciate it Thank You
Denise it's a it's a great subject we
enjoy talking about by the way friends
that frees up a line if you have a Bible
question we do have some lines open one
more time it's 800 God says the callin
with your Bible questions that's 800 are
you ready for six three seven two nine
seven next caller behave is calling from
Calgary Canada we have Mei Hoff nails
welcome to the program
thank you so much how are you doing
great thank you for calling yeah so I
just want to understand more about Luke
17 34 okay I'm going going there right
now I want to read it to everybody
it says and I tell you that in that
night there'll be two men in one bed one
will be taken the other left two women
will be grinding together one taken the
other left two men will be in the field
one taken the other left okay
so I read all three and then it says
where Lord and he said wherever the body
is that's where the Eagles are gathered
together you're wondering where are they
taken yes that's the last one the last
the answer but you can see it yeah well
first of all let me just back up Jesus
is talking about his second coming and
he describes two women in a field two
men in a bed two men in a field there's
two in all three they go opposite places
one saved one is not saved
you see there's two kinds of people
asleep sleep is a symbol for death Jesus
said our friend Lazarus is asleep when
Christ comes there is the dead who are
wicked they are lost and you got the
dead in Christ you've got two kinds of
people that are working in the field
jesus said the harvest is great the
laborers are few you got the true in the
false gospel a woman is like a church
two kinds of women working with the word
grinding the meal the true and the false
and then they said where are they taken
and Jesus said wherever the Eagles the
word Eagle there is a buzzard it's a
vulture
wherever the vulture or wherever the
body is that's where the Eagles go we
had to shoot a bear once and he ran off
from the woods well we knew he died but
we didn't know where a couple days later
we knew where because they were vultures
circling up in the hills and wherever
the body is that's where the vultures
are now notice it says where are they
taken you know the Bible tells us that
they knew not speaking of the lost until
the flood came and took them away now
who is taken away in the flood the flood
came and washed away the wicked and so
God cleaned the world so it's saying
that the wicked are taken away in
judgment when the children of Israel
were disobedient they were carried away
from the promised land
into a land of captivity does that help
answer your question I mean those who
will be taken will go to heaven and
those that would know he's actually
saying that the ones who are taken are
taken away in judgment there's two
different groups view this differently
yeah the ones who are taken away they
were taken away in judgment and if they
said where Lord he said wherever the
body is that's where the Eagles are and
so that group taken away that's not a
happy group and you the children of
Israel if they were left in the promised
land it was considered a blessing if
they were taken away it was a bad
judgment so hey you know we need to keep
going to another question yeah thank you
I appreciate that we're gonna try and
get one more in before our mid program
break next caller that we have is
calling from South Korea I believe we
have Zhi hua calling
south korea jiwa welcome to the program
hello hi thank you for calling in your
question tonight my question comes from
chapter 6 verse 1 and chapter 11 same
book chapter 6 of what book sorry book
of Acts okay
Acts chapter 6 1 and 11 chapter 11 verse
19 okay do you want me to read shall I
read that oh sorry
19 and 20 oh let me just briefly explain
my question um from my understanding it
seems to suggest that the Helenus in
chapter 6 seems to suggest that it's
just Chris Greek speaking Jews because
they're jews and clear one group of jews
are complaining against one other group
of jews and verse 11 verse 20 it seems
to suggest that they were preaching to
the jews only now they're moving on to
gentiles so it's the same word to use
helenus and our question is um how do we
how do I know so I want to ask if my
understanding is correct and also when
abraham believed in jesus i know that he
was he was believing in jesus as a
Gentile not as a Hebrew so my question
is about the Helena stand Gentile and
Jewish how do I know that different all
right well let me do my best we've got
about a minute to try and answer your
question okay okay so you'll see thank
you for that question in the Bible the
Helenus were Greek speaking Jews another
drew a number of Jews had scattered
throughout the Roman Empire and they had
learned some of the customs in the
culture of the Greeks they were
believers in Jehovah but they had been
influenced by the Greek culture it was
called hellenization and but there were
Jews they were Greek speaking Jews and
those widows had been neglected in the
distribution of the food because they
thought that the the more Orthodox
Jewish women they would give them the
food when they distributed to the poor
widows first and the Helenus were
complaining this that were being were
being discriminated against
well the Helenus were also debating
against Stephen in Acts chapter
nine and in yeah acts 9 verse 29 and so
but of course Abraham was not a Hebrew
he's the father of the Hebrews so you
know I guess you'd say everybody was a
Gentile up until the time of Abraham so
I hope that helps a little bit we're
getting ready to take a break we didn't
want to cut you off wanna try and get
some of your question we're not going
away friends you still can call in with
your Bible question we're gonna be back
in just a moment or two with more Bible
answers stay tuned
Bible answers live will return in a
moment
[Music]
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love and great sacrifice but
behind them is another hero hidden in
plain sight amid the shadows he was
there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767 touchin limit and your gift
helps amazing facts bring people to
Jesus call amazing facts today to see
how we can help you get the most out of
your IRA the number to dial is eight
hundred four three six two six nine five
or visit my legacy Tom Mason facts org
if you've missed any of our amazing
facts programs visit our website at
amazing facts org there you'll find an
archive of all our television and radio
programs including amazing facts
presents one location so many
possibilities amazing facts org
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 and also
streaming on the internet to talk about
the Word of God you can go to the
amazing facts Facebook page or the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page and you can see
us here in our humble little studio
looks really impressive on camera but if
we were to pan the cameras around you'd
see that we've kidnapped someone else's
office to produce this program it's kind
of interesting they can make it look so
good on camera but if they could
actually get a 360 they'd see what it
really looks like around here all right
next caller that we have is Stacey in
from Compton California Stacey welcome
to the program hi Stacey you're on the
air oh good and your question I might
have a question what Ezekiel 16 11 and I
wanted to explain about I had a friend
who started wearing jury just based on
this this passage I just want you guys
to explain a little better for him all
right well let me let me read this for
our friends that are listening going to
zekiel chapter 16 and I start with verse
11 I ordained you like two thirteen
start with thirteen you say
no no no from 11:00 tonight they're okay
11 I or III adorned you with ornaments
put bracelets on your wrist and a chain
on your neck I put a jewel in your nose
and earrings in your ears and a
beautiful crown on your head thus you
were adorned with gold and silver and
your clothing was a fine linen silk and
embroidered cloth first of all in the
ancient weddings they didn't have paper
money gold and silver and jewels were
money when Eliezer wanted to thank
Rebecca for watering his camels he gave
her bracelets and earrings and it tells
the weight of them because it was a
payment at a wedding the wedding gifts
were often given to the bride they were
jewels or could be coins that they would
wear on the wedding day now here God is
speaking in an allegory Ezekiel is a
prophet he speak in an allegorical
language of God's marrying his church
said when I found you I gave you great
wealth when they came out of Egypt they
spoiled the Egyptians and the Egyptians
gave them articles of gold and silver
and jewels they then later turned that
into the sanctuary and so God says you
had fine linen silk and embroidered
cloth everything mentioned here was also
in the sanctuary so it's like God was
talking about them being his bride
earlier caller we talked about the
wedding new Jerusalem
that's where God's churches comes down
as a bride adorned and the New Jerusalem
is full of gold and pearls and silver
and so forth so God is not telling us to
wear all these things he's using an
allegory of how he saved Israel how he
gave her great wealth when he brought
them out of Egypt and they had this
beautiful tabernacle and yet they turned
around and worshiped other gods you go
to the New Testament and first of all
you know what did they make a golden
calf out of out of their jewels right
and what did God say break off your
ornaments so I can know what to do with
you and God told Jacob come and meet
with me they buried their jewels and
they came and he met with the Lord so
you know God says let it not be the
outward adorning Christians should be
careful and humble in our
we shouldn't be ostentatious and who was
it a few years ago a bunch of evangelist
got in trouble and someone wrote a song
would Jesus wear Rolex and they were
making fun of these televangelists that
and their wives that were all you know
just heavily bedecked so yeah if I would
not use this verse as very good support
for Christians dressing in with a lot of
ornaments and ostentatious but thank you
hey you know I have a book that I think
you will enjoy that you can share with
your friend
it's called jewelry how much is too much
jewelry how much is too much I think we
all wondered as Christians you see
somebody and they've got not just an
earring on but they got like earrings
going up the ear they're picking up
radio frequencies and their nose and the
eyebrow and the tongue where does it
stop right we'll be happy to send the
book to anyone wanting to learn more
about what if the Bible say with
reference to adorning the number to call
these eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book jewelry how much is too much again
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven we have Bonnie listening from
Ontario Canada
Bonnie welcome to the program thank you
thanks for calling thank you for taking
my question
what I'm wondering is will we see our
pets and having the pets that we love
that become part of our families I know
scripture tells us that there will be
animals in heaven all the way through
the revelation that there will be
animals in heaven but will we be able to
see our pets in heaven you know we
understand that we develop these strong
loving bonds with pets and the animals
and and typically humans outlive their
pets and so you know we have to lay them
in the grave and it's very sad and we
have many fond memories and we wonder is
that the end for them will we ever see
them again in the resurrection there is
no specific scripture we can point to
that will say our particular pets will
be raised of course there are scriptures
several that talk about animals in the
new earth I've got a friend Steve
who wrote a book called will my pet be
in heaven and he makes some compelling
arguments he says that certainly God can
do this you know nothing is too hard for
the Lord God says that he's going to
surprise us you know the eye hasn't seen
or the ear heard things God's prepared
for those that love him and I can
promise you this though
nobody is going to get to heaven bonny
and be unhappy so first of all just be
assured you're going to be happy the
Lord is going to surprise I think the
redeemed
there'll be no painful memories I can't
guarantee you or point you to a
scripture that says you know our
particular pets will be in heaven you
would think that God would want to
resurrect the donkey that spoke to
Balaam and maybe the Raven the Ravens
that brought food to Elijah Elijah yes
so yes you know there are there's some
special animals we read about in the
Bible the donkey that Jesus rode into
Jerusalem you wonder does he get a
chance so I think God's getting surprise
us and that's really all I can tell you
but take a look at see Wahlberg's book
you can just type in will my pet be in
heaven and you can probably order that
online how do I spell his last name no
okay I'm gonna guess w-h-o ell I think
BER G okay I will Google that thank you
so much all right thank you have a
blessed evening but god bless thank you
bye next caller that we have is Stacey
listening in San Bernardino
Stacey welcome to the program thank you
pastures how are you good how are you
doing good I called before my child was
screaming you put me on mute so she's
asleep no sorry I think you probably
recognize my voice so good evening
pastors it's um it's 7:30 8 p.m. here I
do have a Bible question okay so okay so
I have a very very close friend who is
fighting you know we all fight our own
demons with homosexuality he knows the
bottle better than I do and I want to
help him my question is biblically
speaking is
two homosexuals have a chance to be
saved and how can I help my friend and
his struggle well I think I see pastor
Ross is typing a verse and I think he's
looking at the same verse I would think
is that the Corinthians yeah I did I
didn't find a verse well there's a verse
that talks about was so where you once
were but you were saved the Bible is
very clear that there's all kinds of
sins that are listed that will not be in
heaven adulterers thieves Liars and in
that list it's a it's a broad list of
very clear sins homosexuals are listed
now it's talking about people to
practice these things a person may
struggle with the sexual temptation and
frankly it doesn't matter if a person is
struggling with heterosexual temptation
and they are giving into online
pornography even though it's it's
heterosexual or it's a homosexual God is
calling for all believers to be pure and
did you have that verse yeah you'll read
in 1st Corinthians chapter 6 and if you
look from verse 9 through diversity 11
as pastor Doug mentions at lists several
things but verse 11 tells us and such
were some of you but you're washed you
were sanctified you were justified in
the name of our Lord Jesus Christ
so clearly Paul he's describing people
who have experienced conversion a change
in their life and he says you used to
practice these things but now you have
been saved been washed I think in that
list it specifically mentions among
other things homosexuals yes fornicators
idolatrous homosexuals thieves those
covet drunkards and so on
since those that practice those things
will not be in the kingdom of heaven but
those that turn from their sins and
repent whole message of the gospel is
about repenting from sin and whatever
those sins are in sexuality though it's
you know it's sort of has been
normalized in our culture the Bible
hasn't changed people need to turn from
their sins people used to believe you
had to get married before you had sex
and that sort of been normalized by our
culture too
but premarital sex the Bible says it
wrong I guess you can tell I'm
old-fashioned no I like that and I that
go with addiction too they're struggling
with addiction yeah well I think we're
all sin a holic yeah
in other words everybody struggles with
sin and it's only the power of God that
we find victory from whatever those sins
are and so you know it's not like one
person looks down their nose at another
person everybody we've all sinned and
fallen short of God's glory Jesus came
to save us from our sins not in our sins
and that's including addictions yeah
well you know we do have a book that I
think would be good for anyone wanting
to learn more about this it's called
tips for resisting temptation and we'll
be able to send this to anyone who calls
an ass the number is 883 five six seven
four seven again you can just ask for
the book called tips for resisting
temptation you can also read it online
at the amazing facts website thank you
for your call Stacy our next caller is
Roger listening Colorado
Roger welcome to the program hello thank
you for taking my call
absolutely in your question tonight yeah
I'm in hearing a lot about the 70 AD if
there was that important how come in the
Book of Daniel it was never mentioned
the data is not mentioned the event is
mentioned if I think it's in pastoral
I'll have to help me here in when it
talks about and I think it's Daniel
lying where it talks about that the
prints that will come will cause an over
split spreading flood and it describes
that when the Romans came and destroyed
Jerusalem I think that is in Daniel 9
but it doesn't say the date yeah Daniel
9 verse 26 speaking about the
destruction of Jerusalem say shall
destroy the city and the sanctuary the
angel be with the flood and that is a
reference to destruction of Jerusalem in
70 AD by the Romans and that happens one
generation which is 40 years in the
Bible after Christ makes the prophecy
jesus said there will not be left one
stone upon another and he says that in
30 ad a Bible generation he says this
generation will not pass wait at least
things be fulfilled exactly 40 years
later she was almost destroyed by the
Romans so matter of fact it even says
the enemy will come
like an eagle on the the Roman emblem on
their flags was an eagle I think there
are prophecies that talked about the
destruction of Jerusalem in 70 AD okay
but none of it is really yeah somebody
told me that the year the specific date
is not given in Daniel but the event is
talked about okay you're okay thank you
very much for that that helped a lot
because somebody told me that in
Revelation the four horses the white
horse is driven by the Antichrist which
resembles 70 AD which I said wait a
second
God would not do that put an antichrist
on a pure white horse yeah I would
disagree with their interpretation there
in in Revelation I don't know what we
could give that covers the four horsemen
pass I don't think we have a book
specifically about the Forsman but the
white horse would represent the gospel
going forth victorious in the first
century AD and anti grace no just the
opposite yeah typically and then in in
Revelation 19 Christ his picture on a
white horse - right word of God
absolutely hey thank you very much Roger
next one that we have his team are
listening from Massachusetts Tina
welcome to the program um
good evening pastor thank you for taking
my call absolutely and your question I
was raped
um 31 years ago and he he pled guilty
and he went to prison he's been he was
in and out of prison over the years and
the state has always told me whether he
was in prison out of prison and at one
point he raped another woman and then
was in and out of prison smore and okay
last month he I was sent a notice that
he died and I to be honest I was
ecstatic
I was just so happy but then I thought
that I shouldn't be happy and I'm not I
don't know how or I don't know if I
forgiven him I feel like he's stolen so
much for me
and I don't know well and so you're
struggling with how do you forgive yes
and and whether it's okay to feel
relieved that he's dead and I don't have
to worry about ever meeting up with him
yeah you know you shouldn't feel guilty
about feeling relief if you've been
living with a certain amount of fear but
keep in mind that people who do evil
things you know if a person is not born
again if they're not led by God's Spirit
then they're led by selfishness and the
devil and they're gonna act like lost
people and so just keep things in
perspective that this person I don't
know who they are but if they're doing
what you've described they're acting
like lost people act they're doing and
some are doing you know somebody
despicable things so don't let the devil
rob your joy because it robbed this
man's eternity think about that if a man
dies lost what's his next thought he
awakens in the judgment to face all the
deeds he's ever done you really have to
pity a person don't you and to face that
you've lost eternal life don't let don't
let him that anger and that bitterness
consume you
you know when you're born again God
washes away your sin and he washes away
your guilt and even if that guilt is
connected with what someone else did you
you get a whole new beginning so embrace
that you're a new creature
don't let the past even though those
memories are there to say our Lord I'm
I'm thanking you for the new heart the
new life old things are passed away
all things are made new and keep
reminding yourself that and you know
those
angry feelings will start to go away
it's gonna get better
especially now that you know that this
threat is no longer there and then can I
ask you one more question yeah I carry a
firearm because I I just can't let that
happen to me again because it's just for
protection yes and I noticed that
churches many of them in particular come
out and essentially I'm like a pariah is
and so I guess is it wrong because
they're saying that you shouldn't have
firearms but I don't why is that wrong I
mean in the Bible it talks about people
having weapons and even in 1st Samuel 13
it talks about how you know the Hebrews
had no weapons to fight because they
gave them up and so yeah the the
Philistines say they took them all all
right well let me give you a quick
answer because I know we have a couple
more calls waiting there's no Bible
verse that says that it's a sin for a
Christian to use self-defense when it's
necessary when the Bible says turn the
other cheek it's talking about if
someone slaps you I mean it's not
talking about that you should let a
person assault you or your family and
just you know take it mildly without
doing anything to defend yourself in
fact the Bible says that a strong man
will defend his house and if you want to
break into a strong Mans house you got
to bind him so he can't defend his house
so I think the Bible uses common sense
in that area I personally don't have a
problem with you know it depends on you
know if you're living in a dangerous
area I would hope if someone was
threatening you your first thing you do
is fire in the air our son encountered a
bear in the woods he had a gun he was
smart enough not to shoot the bear with
a 22
shot in the air and the bear ran away so
you know a gun could also be a deterrent
that would actually prevent someone from
being injured yourself in somebody else
just depends on your training and and
how you're doing it I always have just
thought of a gun as a tool so yeah I
hope that helps a little bit Tina we'll
keep you in our prayers I know you've
been through a lot and I think the Lord
is going to continue to give you a
healing may explore that we have is Mark
listening in Utah mark welcome to the
program good I'm I'm a long listener of
pastor Doug he's he's answered a lot of
my questions this one is mostly
curiosity but um so it has been there
Emmanuel will be his name God with us
translated and my Bible has that God
with a big jeez so does that mean it's
actually saying eternal one with us and
the other part of that is why does he
call Jesus if it says he's supposed to
be called Emmanuel well actually Jesus
in the Old Testament prophecies there's
a number of names that are used he's
called the branch he's called the
servant he's called Emmanuel he's called
the is it the descendant of David David
yeah
the son of David so so Christ goes by
he's the seed of the woman trying to
think of other Old Testament titles for
Christ but there are many titles that
pointed to the Messiah and so the one
that calls him Immanuel God with us God
became a man and dwelt with us you know
that's a you'll hear that a lot during
the Christmas season we had songs about
it at our Christmas program yesterday
it's one of the names whenever you see
the word L in Hebrew whether it's
Danielle or Rachel or Elijah or Elijah
or Mike L L means Elohim it's one of the
names for God and it's saying God with
us we've been separated from God because
of our sins but through Christ we are
reunited with God one of the wonderful
promises in the Bible is where it says
in Revelation
and God Himself will dwell with us and
we will see him face to face
so hopefully my help in mark so so okay
two speakers so we can say it does say
eternal one because because big G means
eternal one right yeah it's talking
about Jehovah there the talking about
Yahweh the the everlasting God and so
yeah geez you know I actually have a
book that I think you would enjoy talked
about the name of God we will send you
anyone who has a question about this
would be happy to send you a free copy
and all you've got to do is go to the
resource line and ask for the book the
name of God the number two Coley's 808
three five six seven four seven and
again you can ask the book called the
names of God and we'll be happy to send
it out to anyone who calls and asks we
have Jamie listening in West Frankfort
Illinois Jamie welcome to the program hi
how are you doing good we've we've got
about two and a half minutes so got a
quick question yes so real quick I'm I
hate to even ask this because I don't
want people get the wrong opinion I have
a close relationship with God but I'm a
major you know empathy I am very
sensitive have empathy for animals
people like literally everyday if I see
anyone anything hurting um so I know all
about freewill I know the Bible but I
still have anger towards God for not
coming because he's still in control so
it's like I understand free will but
you're ultimately in control this is why
I'm angry at you
you know come back and end all this
great Christian now you know the Lord's
Prayer yeah you know the part that says
thy will be done
yeah do you know why we pray that God's
will will be done because a lot of
what's happening in the world today is
not his will the Bible tells us that the
devil there there's an enemy a very
powerful enemy that has created a
rebellion in the universe that is being
fought
here on our world and God because of the
principles that God lives by he cannot
use a force to just kill all the
creatures that disagree with him he's
allowing the results to play out and I
have a feeling Jamie if you better
understood the battle between good and
evil you'd see that God is very loving
God wants to come he wants to put an end
to all the sin it is hurting him more
that it's hurting anybody but because of
his government and the rules he runs by
God does not just zap with lightning or
squash anyone who asks our questions him
and the devil created rebellion against
God's character he led a third of the
angels to follow him in this rebellion
he came down to our world and he
basically went our first parents
listened to him he set up his
headquarters down here and carrying out
this war against God and God actually
invaded Satan's territory when he came
down into this world to save us Jesus
refers to the devil as the prince of
this world
you know whenever anything bad happens
people say it's an act of God but you
read in the book of Job and it says that
the devil went and the devil caused all
kinds of pain and misery and storms and
fire and every good and perfect gift
comes from God Oh Jamie I spoke really
quick we're running out of time here and
I hope that helps a little bit you would
really enjoy the lesson did God create a
devil we'll send you a free copy of this
lesson it's Illustrated it's got the
whole principle yeah just call 808 three
five six seven four seven ask for the
lesson did God create a devil you know
listening friends it probably would not
be fair to anybody to take another call
so let me just remind you you can listen
to former broadcasts go to amazing facts
dot o-r-g and keep in mind we're
entirely self-supporting you can click
the donate button and keep us on the air
that others might find the truth god
bless you friends
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love than
what went wrong
[Music]
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord factors into last day prophecies
such as the mark of the beast the seal
of God and the great final tribulation
it's all contained in this new
eye-opening DVD series called the last
day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit a
book store calm
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 black so our ji
[Music]